[Music]
good afternoon everybody how's everyone
doing yeah well I hope you're having a
good time here at cloud next my name is
Ankur Kotwal and I'm a developer
advocate on the Google Maps API team
today I want to talk to you about how
you can build with the Google Maps API
for your use cases for your industries
and how the Google Maps API is sit
together to provide great solutions but
before we get too far down that line I
actually want to take a quick trip down
his memory lane the google maps api is
one of the first AP is that google ever
launched and it happened actually a bit
over 11 years ago that's when we first
launched the api's and the the consumer
product the actual Google Maps website
hadn't launched much earlier than that
when we launched the website itself the
consumer product it was the first time
that we were transitioning paper maps to
digital maps now if you think back 11 12
years ago it's not that long ago but
this idea today of us using paper maps
to get anywhere seems quite archaic
we've moved our behaviors have changed
substantially since then we'd pull up
this big folding paper map try and find
your current location in some index
which will give you a page number maybe
or a grid number you'd look it up and
then if you actually had to go somewhere
and you had to find your destination and
you had to route it yourself right
that's today you would pretty much never
do that so as we started to build our
google maps apps we started with the
base map and we started to then add
satellite imagery as well make that
available suddenly we were able to see
the real world from from space
effectively what you can see from space
we added some elevation and terrain but
it was really when smartphones came
along that we hit this inflection point
of usability right suddenly we had the
world in our pocket we had maps in our
pockets we were able to get harnessed
the power of these smartphones to
include things like so
d buildings we were actually able to
direct people they no longer needed to
do things themselves for to get places
and of course places I used that word
just now we were able to now start to
bring semantic meaning to where you are
or where you were going you didn't have
to think about your destination as an
address and that's immensely powerful
and I'll show you why and in the world
we live in today we're very demanding of
our mapping products right we expect
that when we get when we're routing
somewhere when when we're heading to
work let's say that if there is an
incident on the road if there are some
road works if there's an accident if
there's a slowdown that we expect our
apps will actually route us around there
think about doing that in the paper days
and you just kind of try and route to
follow the route that you'd set out and
hope that you you made it on time let
alone try to dynamically right route
yourself around any issues that you came
across and we also have things like
transit we're starting to surface
information about foot traffic as well
but the cool thing is this was our story
for the consumer app we've actually
followed the same story for our AP is
because we believe that developers are
key to this story that we're not the
only ones that can build magical
experiences with this kind of
information and it's the google maps api
s that are powering at with this kind of
information and when you look at our
suite of api's you can then start to see
that those api's can combine together to
address some really interesting use
cases fairly straightforward use cases
like store locators which you might
think is like a pin on a map the store
locators can be so much more than that
real estate agencies use store locators
or a version of store locators to show
their users how what their dream homes
are going to look like what area they're
going to be how close the beaches put on
satellite imagery for a beach house and
you solve the place very quickly
and then look at things consider things
like ride-sharing right today or ride
hailing in the old days we would stand
on the side of the street stick out our
hand hope that a taxi or a cab went past
and was available and we would then be
get on our way today we pull out a phone
right it we're able to then say hey find
me my local my closest taxi it will find
a driver for you but if you think about
the other side of the experience where
you actually tell at your destination
you don't have to type in a full address
anymore you don't have to swipe your map
to get there it happened a few
characters and it autocompletes what
your destination is these apps are smart
enough to remember sort of what your
most popular destinations are where you
came you're going to and the Maps API
czar enabling this great user experience
they are enabling this transition or
this transformation in user behaviors so
look at those use cases and we start to
see these industries that these use
cases can have impact and have positive
impact on we just talked about
transportation and logistics right
thinking about insurance we're able to
see the kinds of foot traffic that you
get in certain areas so if you park your
car out on the streets in a busy area
that insurance premium could be higher
than if you happen to have a garage in
the same area and these industries new
industries are sprouting up all the time
if I had given this talk a year ago I
would not have included gaming on this
slide not because gaming is a new
industry but in the last nine months we
have seen Pokemon go explode right and
it's because that team that brilliant
team at my antics were able to work out
how to make location based gaming or
real world gaming relevant to all these
users and one of the data sources that
they used was our Google Maps API so you
can see that these AP eyes are really
powering big things which brings me to
today's topics which is the Maps API
layers I'm going to present to you four
layers for developing on the Google Maps
API s and the way I'm going to present
this to you is talk to you about use
cases and industries that we're able to
address
each of these I think of this stack as a
developer as a developer stack where you
start at the top there's minimal code
required from your side but as we go
further on the stack we get increased
customizability and control over how we
present our experience so let's start
with delegation and delegation really is
about saying you know what I believe I
need some sort of mapping some sort of
location intelligence in my app but i'm
going to let somebody else handle it for
me i'm going to let Google handle it for
me for whatever isn't it could be for
development constraint reasons or it
might just not be a core piece of
functionality in your app and on Android
we have this this this mechanism called
intense where you can from one app in
ten out to another app and you can
provide some additional context so that
it can initialize that other app to
whatever it is that you're looking for
so if you look at these intense here the
first thing we're doing is loading a map
of San Francisco so this is where in
your app you might want to send your
users you want to provide them a nap a
map of some sort centered around San
Francisco and in three lines of code you
can say hey give me that latitude
longitude which is on line one we create
that you are I create an intent passing
that URI in and then we set this package
that says hey send it off the maps and
then start activity for lines of code we
can also do it for things like actual
searches so maybe we don't know the
actual destination we want to go we're
just doing some discovery so here we put
in the lat/long that we talked about at
the start we also that added a query for
restaurants we can kick off navigation
because many apps kind of want to direct
sort of point users to their destination
but not necessarily control that
navigation experience we can do that and
here we're going to Toronto Zoo in
Australia we can even fire up street
view now we talked about Android here
you can achieve the same thing on iOS
and on iOS a similar thing is called the
comparable feature is called URL scheme
so if you look at the demo on the left
we're just hitting launch and it's
actually firing up the browser
now what I'm going to show you is the
iOS code to achieve this and the reason
that there's more code on iOS is one its
objective c so it's a little bit more
verbose but to that first if condition
that block is checking whether the user
has the Google Maps app installed if it
does it's going to use it so on Android
you can you can be fairly confident that
users are going to have google maps on
iOS it's it's sort of a personal
preference some users will have it many
users will have it some users want and
so a piece of code like this in that
first if block we're able to check head
you have the app if so fire up google
maps if not just fall back to the
browser and we're able to accomplish the
same things so that's simple that's
that's that first layer delegation we're
not really doing anything inside of our
apps we're letting some were letting
Google handle it for us layer 2 of this
stack is incorporation where we want to
put a little bit of mapping
functionality in but again we want to
it's fairly light functionality we just
want a simple map and here on the
website you could use the static Maps
API the cool thing about the static Maps
API is is just the URL that you pass in
and you put in the the parameters that
you need so we said the center is a
particular location we specify the zoom
levels we can even specify a resolution
and our API key and this will return
back as an image so the nice thing about
this is there is no JavaScript involved
you just put an image tag with this URL
around it and you're away we give you
some customization options as well so as
you can see from the three screenshots
we've applied a custom style on the very
left hand side it's a monochrome style
on the second slide we've used a
satellite imagery and on the third one
we've actually drawn a line that there's
a blue line in the middle that's sort of
navigating you from I think in this case
is my hotel room to my office in in
mountain view but if you want to go
beyond static Maps if you want to make
it interactive if you don't want just
the picture we have the embed API and
that allows you to embed a map onto your
side right it'll put it in a nice little
frame there and you're doing it by
specifying an iframe and you can do
things like again
provide directions or even the street
view so we're just starting to touch the
surface of some of the mapping
functionality we can do now for the next
piece of incorporation I'm going to look
at a specific use case and that's a
location sharing now it may not be
obvious to everybody but location
sharing is actually something we do very
often and it's useful in many many
contexts right it might be as simple as
just letting your family member know
that you're running late because you're
stuck in traffic you might location sure
I'm stuck in traffic I'm here right it
could be that you're saying I I need to
get somewhere so going back to our our
ride sharing application where we're
trying to find a taxi for us we usually
share our current location so we can get
picked up there now that might seem like
a lot of work but we've tried to make it
really really easy easy for you as
developers and easy for your users and
there's two things I'm going to talk
about here the first one is the place
picker and the place picker is really
it's a UI widget that you can just drop
into your app and it provides this
fantastic user experience I'm going to
kick off the animation but you have a
map in the middle you can drag it around
you can drop it on a pin and then below
that map we actually have a list of
locations so in case you don't want to
interact with the map you can just pull
up the list of locations and identify
which place you're at there's also a
search box at the top so you can type in
which location you're at but the nice
thing is we provide an out-of-the-box
user experience that's very familiar to
users and is powered by the google maps
api s so you know it's going to be
accurate and you can trust it it's an
easy way to have your usually share
their location because I can just pick
what's there the nice thing is it
requires very little code so on Android
we have two parts to this code the first
part is we're going to start off the
place picker activity we're going to say
ahead go ahead and show the place picker
we create one of these play speaker in
10 builders and then we hit we call this
method start activity for result and the
reason we call that method is because we
want to know when the user has finished
selecting a place that that process has
finished a neck
parts of the result so once the user
goes and interacts with this widget we
get a call back we just confirmed that
it's we've come back because of the
place picker and then we get the place
that the user selected couldn't be
easier right and suddenly location
sharing which can be a hugely complex
affair you imagine trying to code an
experience like this dropping a map in
having scrollable lists using GPS or
Wi-Fi to actually populate those lists
in a meaningful way it's not necessarily
trivial code but we've trivialized it by
providing this out of the box widget and
we have parody on iOS as well so on iOS
again it's a similar amount of code
we're going to instantiate AGMs place
picker config we're going to go ahead
and kick it off so it displays the pay
sticker and when we get the call back
we're just going to pull that place you
see that last if condition there we're
just going to pull the place out of it
in this case we're getting the place
names that's it that's how easy it is to
share location another example where our
ride sharing application might be useful
is something called autocomplete so if
you think about ride-sharing when we
want to get picked up we always have a
place to go so if you think about your
your ride sharing app you look up my
your destination you know I'm not a fan
of the keyboard on mobile devices so I
don't like to type a lot right it's not
easy to do we it's easy to make typos
and so on autocomplete here is powered
by the same magic that powers goggle
search and Google Maps in terms of it's
sort of recognizing what your intent is
with few characters right so an
autocomplete widget makes a lot of sense
whenever you need to ask the user for an
address of any sort right they can look
by name they can look by by its address
if they really wanted they could
probably look like a latitude longitude
as well but really humans don't work in
that way anyways on iOS I having an
autocomplete widget is similar the
amount of code is similar to the play
speaker we are creating one of these
auto complete view controllers we're
firing it off we get a call back at the
bottom there with the place that the
user selected and we're able to pull the
name app on Android again the code
very similar we have an intent for the
place autocomplete we go ahead and call
startactivityforresult and we get the
result back so location sharing becomes
simple yet very refined as a user
experience so that's some examples of
incorporation but I know most of the
developers I work with the like I really
want to go deeper I don't I want to be
able to write some code myself and
produce some magic and that's really
what integrations layer 3 is about it's
about saying hey you know what this Maps
API I want to use it I want the data
from it I want to customize it I want to
really make it my own I want to
personalize it and the use case where
this becomes immensely useful is when
you want to visualize a map all right so
let me show you this particular demo
here well it's a screenshot so Google
i/o is our other large conference for
developers and we have that annually and
in 2016 google i/o for the first time
was actually held at our campus in
mountain view now mountain view is
actually quite far from the main san
francisco city and we knew that there
would be a lot of people that would be
traveling from all over the world to
this conference so what we did is that
we organized buses to pick up these
attendees from various hotels and
various parts of San Francisco City and
actually all around the bay area and
they would these these buses would then
take these attendees to the conference
and back when we thought you know what
would be great is we if we could show a
demonstration of our Google Maps API and
display on a dashboard our bus tracker
so we built a bus tracker and if you
look at this this layer 3 of integration
what we're doing here is that we've
we've grabbed the usual standard jazz
Maps API v3 but we've custom styled it
we've put custom markers on there to
represent buses and represent hotels
we're using polygons to draw the path of
that the buses are taking and then we
have some just standard HTML elements
that sit on top that tell you where
these buses are going which stops which
hotel
is going to be stopping at but we also
added time estimates so if you look at
the top of the boxes it says leaving in
next in and then on the left-hand side
it tells you time estimates of how long
it's going to take to get to those spots
and we're using the directions API to
get those time estimates but i'll talk
about the directions API a little bit
later but here is an example of
integration where we really change the
visualization of how these maps are now
if you're interested in an example like
this we actually open source to this
only a couple of weeks ago so if you go
to github com / google maps look for
transport tracker you can see the full
source code for this and use it for your
your purposes as well now we've had
custom styling on maps for the web
version for the jsapi for a number of
years and one of the biggest requests
that we've had from developers is when
is it coming to android and iOS so it
was only a couple of months ago that we
were thrilled to be able to launch
custom styling for Android and iOS and
as you can see from the animated
screenshot here it works exactly as
you'd expect you can change the style at
runtime right and you don't need to tear
the map down and bring it back up you
just call set style and it goes ahead
and applies it so examples of where this
could be useful is if you're building a
fitness app or some sort of driving a
poor navigation app if you change the
style to reflect the time of day so as
it hits evening time we're able to
switch into a night mode theme and vice
versa the other really cool thing about
the way we did custom styling is that
you specify your styles using a JSON
file right and we provided a styling
wizard so if you just do a google search
for a google map styling wizard you'll
get to a site where you can see a map
and you get a bunch of really friendly
sliders and radio buttons where you can
custom style your map for you and it can
export a JSON file now the nice thing
about that JSON file is it's the same
format whether you want to use custom
styling on the web on Android or
a single file and you can either ship
that Jason file on your app or website
or you can host it yourself and then at
runtime dynamically pull down whatever
is your current style so we give you
full flexibility there it's not just
about changing colors you can actually
turn on or off landmarks you can change
the density of labels so maybe you don't
care for points of interest in your app
or you don't need to show as many roads
we have sliders that enable you to turn
that up or down there's a ton of
flexibility here and this is the type of
integration and that attention to detail
in your apps that makes your apps shine
and stand out so that's how we look at
the map as a whole I want to switch
gears and talk a little bit about the
camera so if you see here this is
downtown Los Angeles we're just going to
Android app we've focused on downtown
Los Angeles and this is a style of map
that you used to seeing in fact you can
see the heritage of paper maps coming
through here but we're on a digital
device and realistically if you are
let's say building a real estate app and
you want to show people what the next
dream home could look like showing them
some perspective of that map is a much
better user experience than necessarily
showing it from top down now having this
sort of depth 3d buildings really nicely
zoomed in and having tilt that's not
necessarily applicable for every use
case but you can certainly see having
this sort of rich visualization in
certain types of apps like the real
estate up add a lot of value to your
users and do pulling this sort of thing
off is incredibly simple we have when
you specify a new camera position on
Android you have to create one of these
camera position objects and we have a
couple of methods on there so some of
these values you should recognize things
like target which is the latitude and
longitude where you want to focus on
things like zoom which is how far in you
are but then bearing allows you to turn
the camera basically like a compass to
see which direction you're facing and
tilt is the thing that
comes in and and put some depth on it so
bring that camera really closer down to
the surface if you choose just adding
those extra parameters and the gist
numeric values adds so much more to the
experience of your app and the other
thing that I recommend is that as you
change your camera position don't just
snap the camera to place don't move the
camera use AP is like this one called
animate camera and what animate camera
does is it works out the difference
between where it's the the cameras
looking at now compared to where it
needs to be and it gracefully animates
the camera there in a nice smooth flow
right so if your users are going through
let's say houses will continue with that
example in a list and it's selecting the
next one don't just jump the camera
there move them help them keep that
retain that context of where they're
moving to and where they came from on
iOS we achieve the same thing again with
with iOS in objective-c we use the GMs
camera position object instead we have
the at the bottom of those parameters
you can see bearing e and instead of
tilt on iOS it's called viewing angle
that means exactly the same thing and as
you can see with this demo here we have
the same sort of depth 3d buildings and
so on let's have a look at another use
case a store locator and as I mentioned
earlier store locators are much more
than just a marker on a map right you
can make them very rich and useful
beyond just one particular point so
here's what i did i was a little bit
naive and I searched for Italian
restaurants in Rome and I managed to get
quite a few results here it shouldn't be
a surprise to anybody just dropping
markers where all these Italian
restaurants are this is not a great user
experience right imagine trying to make
sense of this like hey you know I'm
visiting Rome and like where should I go
and eat this there's really not much to
be gained from here
a better way to present this is with
something that we call marker clustering
and this is what market clustering looks
like you'll see that some clusters there
and as we zoom in those clusters split
apart and we're able to see more
concentrations of these markers but as
we zoom out and they start to overlap we
coalesce them they group up into these
clusters and visually we put a count on
there so that your user can kind of see
you know that this is an important
cluster or not so we actually change the
size of the cluster we put numbers
around it and so on this is part of an
open-source library and I'll tell you
about that library in a second so you
can customize all of this let me show
you how much code is required to
implement marker clustering in your apps
the first thing you need to do is tell
your Gradle in your Gradle configuration
specify that you want to use the Android
Maps you tools library the second thing
you need to do is look at your data
class and in our case our data class is
going to be our list of restaurants
right so we'll have restaurants with
name and lat long and whatever else
maybe it'll be rating cost and any any
number of things but all we need to do
is add this one implement this interface
is one extra method called get position
which just returns its latitude
longitude once we have that done we
create or instantiate one of these
cluster managers and we tell our map
that any time the camera changes or the
user clicks on the map that they should
use that that the map should let the
cluster manager know about it and that's
how when we interact with the map those
clusters are like coalescing and forming
new ones or splitting up and then step
four we go ahead and tell our cluster
manager but here are all our restaurants
I didn't put the step 5 on there but the
step 5 is that you should go ahead and
remove any code that you have to add
markers onto the map or take markers are
out of the map because the cluster
manager is going to do that for you so
in these sort of 10 to 15 lines of code
we suddenly implemented cluster marker
marker clustering and we've probably
reduced the amount of code that we had
from before we started so great user
experience with minimal effort from a
development standpoint
instead of mark instead of clusters we
can also do heat maps and the heat map
implementation looks similar to clusters
where we generate these heat maps
depending on zoom levels and so as we
zoom in more and more you start to see
the heat map sort of start to split
apart or when we zoom out it combines
into larger ones now I mention this is
an open source library so if you don't
like my alarming colors you can
definitely change that the API itself
allows you to change that as well but
it's it's very easy to do again the
implementation for this is trivial the
same library that we use we add that
that interface we have on our data items
we then instantiate a heat map tile
provider this is the thing that's going
to generate the tiles depending on zoom
levels and lat Long's on that step 2 I
just wanted to point out the dot data
that's where we add our restaurants
right it's just that one line it's going
to manage it for us and then step three
we add a tile overlay and we add it to
the map itself that's it that's the
whole code for the heat map
implementation so when it comes to doing
deep integration really look at things
like custom styling personalize your
Maps look at ways that you can uniquely
present whatever data it is that you
want to present on a map don't overwhelm
your users use the visual metaphors
where possible all right so we've gotten
to the point where we've done some
integration but I've had developers come
and tell me but anchor I just want the
raw data you know what I will manage
everything I want to do it I want to
control everything I want to be the
orchestrator or all of this so let's
look at an example in sleep NASA
tracking right in typically with sleet
and NASA tracking we have a number of
vehicles we need to do some deliveries
we need to optimize around that there's
a number of api's that can really help
here the first is the directions API now
the directions API is a web service
right so you can call it on any platform
but we do we do recommend that you proxy
it any of our web services through a
server rather than consume them directly
on mobile and if you want to know more
about why that is we had a
talk today called the development best
practices for google maps of web
services it will be up on YouTube within
a day or so so please do look that up we
cover some great best practices there
back to the directions API the great
thing about the directions apos one that
returns you this nice JSON output it
tells you step-by-step directions on how
to get somewhere it tells you exactly
attitude and longitudes on how to get
your users to places you can specify
different travel modes whether you're
driving so in your in the use case we
were talking about the asset tracker it
might be a driving delivery that we're
doing or might be cycling we could do
that too but at the bottom there you'll
see duration we can actually give you
travel times of how long it's going to
take so either to complete this journey
and that's immensely powerful and very
very useful for things like our ride
sharing service that we talked about
earlier or even any delivery service
that we're going to do now this
information is powered by the same
engine that powers Google Maps a dozen
Avigail that provides real-time
directions we can take this one step
further let's say our business isn't
actually asking for this information
right now but they care about the
delivery time at 3am tomorrow morning we
have predictive travel times for that so
what we've done is over time we built
this hugely complicated models of
traffic for for all over the world we've
put it through a machine learning
algorithms and develop new machine
learned models out of that and we're
applying it to understand traffic
conditions not just now but when there
will be at various times of the week at
various points in the world and of
course if you know that your vehicle is
going to be on a road you should
consider using the roads API something
that actually surprises a lot of folks
is when they're told that the gps on
their phones regardless of which phone
you have it's actually not that accurate
right there are times unless there's a
perfect line of sight it's often not
very accurate it gives you a range of
values
and so even though you're driving along
a straight road you could get a GPS
response up here up here down there
across there I mean overall you're going
straight and you could kind of start to
see that pattern but the actual data
that it gives you is not necessarily
straight so I'm going to say computer
enhance and we're going to look at this
data that we recaptured so this is a car
that was traveling around this park and
around some buildings and what you can
see here is apparently this car cut
across a park drove through the park and
further down actually drove through a
building as well now you can judge my
driving however you want but I did not
do that the roads API can help us
eliminate these sorts of problems noisy
GPS so what we did is we then took those
exact same points put them through the
roads API and we ended up with the green
line and the roads API is intelligent
enough to know that hey look this is I
know that this vehicle is on a road
throughout this journey I'm going to
look at this data and I'm going to
interpolate what is actually happening
here and so will snap those points to
the road but when you've got like curved
roads and things as well it will
actually smooth that path out it will
add new points to that list of latitude
longitude so that when you plot it it
looks nice and smooth rather than a
jagged polygon so the roads API is
immensely useful let's look at local
discovery as a use case now in the case
of local discovery we just want to see
we want to learn about other places
around the particular location so I'm
from Sydney Australia and so when I
visit San Francisco one of the things
that I tend to do is hey which
restaurants should I go and check out
which bars you know what attractions
there are and one of the API is where we
provide this information in is the
places API and the places API is
something that we provide is a web
service as well as a native API on
Android and iOS I'm going to cover both
with the places API you can get lots of
information about a place because if you
think about a latitude and longitude
it's a point on earth it doesn't make a
lot of sense when you're in a
multi-story building in fact if you're
in a multi-story building like the
Moscone Center today you're not even
going to get a GPS location because we
don't have direct line of sight with the
satellites we're indoors we're also not
at a specific we're not just at a
latitude and longitude we have to
consider height and this is where places
can help places that is able to tell you
the difference between being on floor
three of this building versus floor too
if you're in a shopping mall you can
actually tell whether you're at a cafe
or a hairdresser even if there's
somewhere close by and the way it does
is is it does this is by using
information like latitude and longitudes
Bluetooth beacons Wi-Fi access points
and more as well as assisted GPS which
is triangulating cell phone tower
information as well but the great thing
is once you have a place it has a ton of
semantic information so here's a
response that we get from the Jason
request I've highlighted a couple of
things I'm just going to talk through
those the first one is formatted address
this is actually a big challenge to
solve as a developer because if you're a
delivery or a logistics company
especially a global one the way
addresses are formatted in different
parts of the world varies drastically
all right some places put have something
called a zip code some places have a
postcode some use numbers some use
letters some put the state before the
zip code some put them after and getting
that right can mean the difference
between your customer receiving their
package on time or either not getting it
or getting it late or not at all right
and the places API is able to format
this for you exactly to the destination
so we handle that complexity for you we
give you the latitude and longitude we
also give you the name but you're also
able to get some additional metadata you
can get photos of the place you can get
information like a ratings of what the
users have said about it you can get the
establishment type is it
the library's at a place of worship is
it a bar so there's tons of great
information and if you use the places
API in your apps the thing to remember
is to hold on to this thing at the
bottom called the place ID which is a
unique identifier for every place in the
world because once you have that place
ID you can retrieve any place details
you want so it's a great way to do a
local discovery up use the places API do
a place search and find what types of
places that are around and you can
filter by establishment types on the web
service for the Android and iOS API we
repurposed built the places API for
specific use cases so rather than
searching anywhere in the world we
wanted to make this a lot more
contextual so this is very much about
the places around you so in android we
call it get current place or current
place with call back on iOS and i'm
going to show you a quick demo what
happens is when when we use the sensors
on a phone we give you a list of places
that the user is likely to be at and
some values now you don't need to see
these values specifically clearly just
know that these likelihood values are
going to be between 0 and 1 and the
closer it is to one the more confident
we are that the user is at that place so
here's a demo we're driving along the
101 and you'll see that the list of
places that we're getting back is
changing the moving up and down and the
likelihood is changing as well as we
move along that route and that's where
you can really use this places API to
determine where a user is and so in that
location-sharing example we talked about
earlier I showed you the place picker
the get current place is the API that
powers the place picker so if you want
to orchestrate it yourself you can do
that it's a bit more work for you but
certainly gives you all the data and
information you need to make a good user
decision now we've just talked about a
number of web services today they're
really really useful in different
contexts we looked at some use cases we
looked at some solutions now you might
find that you need to use these web
services on different platforms and even
though web services can be consumed on
any platform we've tried to make that
development easier for you we've built a
number of client libraries
and we built them for go for Python for
node.js and for java and they're open
sourced they're available at github com
/ google maps and not only do they make
it easier to consume these web services
on in those languages but we've actually
also put in some additional features all
right we've made authentication really
really easy we've added exponential
back-off for when you have any failures
we've also made it so that you can call
that api synchronously or asynchronously
depending on whatever style of
development you're using so it's worth
checking these up so that brings me to
the close of this presentation we've
talked about these four layers of
development delegation incorporation
integration and orchestration we've
looked at them in the context of various
use cases to build great solutions
everything I've talked about today is
actually available on
developers.google.com / maps so we're
all about developer documentation lives
and it links out to things like a github
repository as well so please do check it
out I want to thank you for coming today
I'm going to open it up for Q&A right
now thank you questions if you do have a
question if you can just come to the
microphone we have one right in the
middle here that would be great
uncle great great talk you gave a lot of
perspective and functionality on
functionalities that you're offering
around basically location-based services
navigation point location I mean of
course Google Maps also has a ready rich
collection of satellite imagery so i'll
have you been thinking to to take some
of that data out and put it through an
API just the imagery itself just damaged
regionals like yeah we don't really do
that in a big way today we the best sort
of in the Maps API specifically you can
get maps and just change the map style
to an image but if you're looking for
map tiles specifically it's not
something that we make readily available
in this context yeah if you use some of
the custom styling stuff so it depends
on what exactly what your use cases the
closest you could get is that if you use
a define a custom style and turn off all
the like labels and and things for roads
and then set the map type to satellite
you could get a fairly yeah you could
get a good sort of satellite view but it
really depends on what you're doing that
might not be sufficient
well I'm going to be here on the side if
anybody has any follow-up questions the
other thing I I also we should mention
is that tomorrow we've got a number of
great talks on on the maps ideas we're
going to be looking at topics on
specific verticals like gaming we're
going to be talking looking at
ride-sharing we have some interesting
talks on geolocation as well and
location intelligence so I hope you're
able to join us and for those of you
that are watching on YouTube you can
certainly find those talks will be
publishing them on the Geo developers
blog and on youtube as well so thank you
very much everybody i hope you enjoyed
the rest of the conference
[Music]